hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live sie sind eigentlich unsichtbar und
gleichzeitig unfassbar wichtig an
unserem Meeresgrund liegen unzählige
naja unzählige nicht aber ganz wichtige
auf jeden Fall Kabel für kritische
Infrastruktur Pipelines Unterseekabel
für unsere Gas Internet und
Stromversorgung und seit gestern können
wir alle sehen gar nicht mehr unsichtbar
wie das aussieht wenn sie defekt sind
hier seht ihr neben mir im Bild die
Bilder in der Ostsee riesengroße
blasenteppiche denn drei große Lex sind
in den Pipelines nornes Nord Stream 1
und Nord Stream 2 gerissen worden und so
sieht das aktuelle in der Ostsee aus
Pipelines die eigentlich von Russland
Gas nach Deutschland zu uns bringen aber
aktuell und auch schon die Zeit davor
lieferten sie gar kein Gas
nichtsdestotrotz sind sie jetzt
beschädigt und an einen Zufall glaubt
niemand mehr und in unserer Sendung ist
Thema was im Moment los ist dort in der
Ostsee wie groß ist denn die Gefahr
jetzt wo wir gesehen haben dass
Pipelines dort beschädigt worden sind
wie groß ist die Gefahr für unsere
Infrastruktur unter Wasser das ist heute
unsere Frage in diesem Stream unser
Thema und ihr könnt dazu natürlich
Fragen und Kommentare stellen und die in
den Stream schreiben oder per Mail in
die Adresse die ihr gerade eingeblendet
seht die Bundesregierung die hat sich
auch schon geäußert heute dazu und sagt
heute es gäbe Erkenntnisse dass es keine
natürliche Ursache für diesen Vorfall
geben kann für diese drei Lecks und
darüber wollen wir heute sprechen wir
haben uns dazu eingeladen den
Fregattenkapitän Göran swisstek erst
Experte für maritime Sicherheit in der
Ostsee arbeitet für die Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik schönen guten
Abend Herr swistig guten Abend
seit gestern wissen wir also es gibt
diese drei legs die Pipelines sind
beschädigt jetzt heißt es also es geht
auch niemand mehr von einem Zufall aus
was weiß man denn heute schon mehr weiß
man wer dahinter steckt was dahinter
steckt was gibt's neues
also die Informationslage zu diesen Lex
ist noch relativ dünn man kann versuchen
die bekannten Informationen so ein
bisschen wie ein Puzzlespiel
zusammenzulegen um sich einen Überblick
zu verschaffen sie haben bereits erwähnt
es gibt drei legs drei Zwischenfälle hat
es gegeben am Montag das eine etwas
südöstlich von Bornholm das andere oder
die anderen beiden nordöstlich von
Bornholm beide außerhalb der Hoheit
Gewässer Dänemarks Bornholm gehört zu
Dänemark aber innerhalb der
ausschließlichen Wirtschaftszone sowohl
von Dänemark wie auch angrenzend an
Schweden die Zwischenfälle sind passiert
oder die Pipelines liegen dort wo es
passiert ist auf einer Wassertiefe von
70 Metern anhand der Bilder kann man
sehen dass eine ganze Menge Gasaustritt
wir wissen auch dass seismografische
Sensoren eine eine Erschütterung
aufgezeichnet haben die vermutlich in
Verbindung zu bringen ist mit der
Zerstörung dieser Pipelines das heißt
hier gab es eine vermutlich Explosion
die Zerstörung zeigt dass dieses Ausmaß
wie es passiert ist nicht natürlich ein
Ausmaß nicht natürlicher Ursache sein
kann die Pipelines selber nun bin ich
kein
Techniker aber die sind so gebaut dass
sie sowohl dem jeweiligen Untergrund
standhalten der kann mal felsig mal
steinig mal schlammig sein aber auch
verschiedenen Witterungseinflüssen wenn
es Sturm gibt oder Bewegung auf See aber
auch externe Einflüsse sollte mal ein
Schiff z.B aus Versehen sein Anker dort
niederlassen die Pipelines sind so
aufgebaut dass Sie das ab können die
bestehen aus mehreren Zentimetern Stahl
darum ist noch mal ein Mantel aus Zement
und verschiedene andere Schichten die
solche
Schockzustände auch absorbieren können
von daher kann man sagen dass das nicht
natürlich ein Ausmaß ist das wäre jetzt
meine nächste Frage aber wer könnte denn
eigentlich dazu in der Lage sein so so
sehr diese Pipelines zu beschädigen also
was für ein Gerät was muss man dafür
haben sie haben gerade angesprochenen
Anker kann aber nicht sein dazu ist das
auch viel zu massiv was da also passiert
ist wer wäre dazu in der Lage
theoretisch
ich würde hier gern paar Aspekte
betrachten zum einen das Verbringen von
Explosivstoffen auf so eine Wassertiefe
und auch die Menge an Explosivstoffen
die ich brauche um so eine Zerstörung
hervorzurufen das kann nicht jeder
beliebige Mensch diese Explosivstoffe
kann ich auch nicht auf dem freien Markt
kaufen die werden wahrscheinlich
militärischer Natur sein das Verbringen
dazu muss ich dann entsprechend
trainiert das Personal haben auf 70
Meter Wassertiefe kann das auch nicht
jeder Taucher so viel Explosivstoffe
verbringen und dann noch mit Zündern
oder anderen technischen Geräten
anbringen
da würde ich die Variante Taucher
erstmal ausschließen persönlich oder
eher als unwahrscheinlich betrachten die
Variante die ich auch oft höre sind
U-Boote nun gut U-Boote operieren hin
und wieder in der Ostsee die Ostsee ist
aber kein ideales ob U-Boot
Operationsgebiet gerade dort ab Bornholm
beginnt so der Bereich wo U-Boote
operieren können aufgrund der
Wassertiefe das zieht sich dann hoch bis
nach Estland da habe ich so Wassertiefen
bis zu 200 300 Meter der können U-Boote
sich verstecken und agieren ansonsten
habe ich aber in der Ostsee und gerade
in den Zugängen Wassertiefen von 20 oder
30 Metern da werden U-Boote nicht
tauchen sie sind leicht zu entdecken zu
überwachen man hätte also vorher gesehen
wenn U-Boote in dem Bereich einfahren
oder auch demnächst oder jetzt ausfahren
das wäre eine Indikation ich bin mir
sicher dass gerade auch diese
Überwachung der militärischen Geräte von
U-Booten relativ gut funktioniert von
den
ostseeanrainern die Variante U-Boot
halte ich da ja auch relativ
unwahrscheinlich für unwahrscheinlich
muss ich ehrlich sagen eine andere
Möglichkeit ist es natürlich das ganze
auch über Drohnen oder unbemannte
unterwassersysteme zu verbringen die
durchaus in der Lage sind Arbeiten unter
Wasser durchzuführen oder auch
bestimmtes technisches Gerät oder in dem
Fall Explosivstoffe zu verbringen das
ist möglich das kann ich von jedem
beliebigen Mutterschiff so würde ich das
mal nennen tun das heißt Mutterschiff
ich brauche irgendwo eine ein Schiff ein
das kann ein ziviler Frachter oder ein
anderes Schiff sein was erstmal diese
Drohne in das Seegebiet bringt aussetzt
und dann von wo aus sie auch gesteuert
wird
geleitet wird da das jedes beliebige
Schiff sein kann ist es auch schwer
solche Aktivitäten zu erkennen wer hat
solches Material ja da kommen auch nicht
so viel Staaten so viel Akteure in Frage
es haben natürlich auch Unternehmen
solches Material aber in Verbindung mit
Explosivstoffen würde ich da eher in die
Richtung staatliche Akteure gucken aus
meiner eigenen Forschung weiß ich dass
Russland in den letzten Jahren ein sehr
starkes Forschungsprogramm in der
Unterwasserwelt aufgebaut hat die
Unterwasserwelt ist noch eine der
Bereiche sage ich mal wo man sich am
besten verstecken und agieren kann alles
was so über Wasser an Land in der Luft
ist da kann ich mit
Radarsensoren mit Satellitenüberwachung
ziemlich gut erkennen was da tagtäglich
passiert rund um die Uhr unter Wasser
gibt es solche Sensoren weniger oder
kaum und ich kann schlecht überwachen
was da passiert
da hat Russland ein Forschungsprogramm
entwickelt das wissen wir man hat
umbenannte Drohnen unter Wasser
Fahrzeuge entwickelt die man erprobt hat
auch schon eingesetzt hat die sind auch
in der Lage unter Wasser Arbeiten
durchzuführen oder Material mit zu
tragen mitzuführen das hat man vor allen
Dingen in den letzten na ich würde mal
sagen acht Monaten ganz stark im
Nordatlantik und ein Nordsee beobachtet
wo es eine Korrelation also ein
Zusammenhang gab mit dem Aufenthalt von
russischen Forschungsschiffen und
Kriegsschiffen die solche drohen
verbracht haben was zufälligerweise auch
immer recht nah oder direkt über von
kommunikationskabeln war gerade im
Nordatlantik laufen sehr viele
Kommunikationskabel die uns mit Amerika
verbinden aber auch mit den Inseln
Island Grönland im Nordatlantik
und natürlich ist noch so einem Angriff
jetzt oder nach so einer Beschädigung
der Pipelines die Sorge groß dass das
also nicht nur für nordstream 1 und 2
gilt passiert weil das sind ja auch
gerade die Pipelines wir hatten es am
Anfang der Sendung schon erwähnt wo wir
gerade gar kein Gas bekommen aber es
gibt eben noch andere Pipelines und
kritische Infrastruktur unter Wasser und
wir haben in einem Beitrag von meinem
Kollegen Thomas gonsion nun einmal eine
kleine Zusammenfassung was ich dort noch
so unter Wasser befindet
die Bilder sind schon mehr als 20 Jahre
alt sie zeigen aber etwas von aktueller
Bedeutung diese Gasleitung europeype
damals verlegt soll Deutschland im
Winter mit Energie versorgen zwei von
ihnen je gut 600 Kilometer bringen Gas
von Norwegen durch die Nordsee zu uns
ebenso die Verbindung nur pipe wichtig
weil Nord Stream 1 und 2 in der Ostsee
nicht für Lieferungen in Frage kommen
was schon vor den lexs klar war die
Frage nun sind die Pipelines sicher
schützt sie jemand von einer abstrakten
Gefährdungslage spricht das
Innenministerium ihre Chefin sagt die
Bundespolizei ist mit ihren Schiffen 24
Stunden am Tag und sieben Tage in der
Woche auf Nord- und Ostsee unterwegs
sprich sie sollen Schutz geben aber
reicht das zu viel Pipeline für zu
wenige Grenzschützer auch international
sagen Experten diese Partners lassen
sich nicht lückenlos kontrollieren
sind ja sehr sehr lange strenge die über
viele hundert Kilometer zum Beispiel in
der Ostsee laufen zweifelhaft auch ob
die Behörden über genug Mittel verfügen
etwa unter Wasser Drohnen abzufangen
eine solche britische dient der
Minenräumung denkbar grundsätzlich aber
ein Einsatz zur Sabotage Fazit die
Sicherheitslage ist sehr schlecht das
kann man nur in aller Klarheit so sagen
Deutschland ist ein hoch vulnerables
Land und Deutschland hat wie in fast
allen Bereichen die seine Sicherheit
betreffen auch hier in den vergangenen
30 Jahren nahezu alles verschlafen und
nun Norwegens premier störe verspricht
heute einen stärkeren Fokus auf Luft und
See er sieht keine konkrete Gefahr für
Energieanlagen wie gesagt es sind auch
jene für Deutschlands Wärme im Winter
wir haben es gerade gehört Norwegen
sieht keine konkrete Gefahr für
Energieanlagen wir haben eine Frage aus
dem Stream dazu von Tobias der möchte
gerne wissen wie viel sicherer sind denn
die Pipelines mit Norwegen wird die
U-Boot Jagd in der Nordsee jetzt
verstärkt
zu der kritischen Infrastruktur sei es
Pipelines sei es aber auch Offshore
Windparks sei es Datenkabel die auch auf
dem Meeresboden liegen würde ich erstmal
anmerken die sind vom Betreiber sind
erstmal in Hand ziviler privater
Betreiber die sind von den Betreibern
auch ausgerüstet mit gewissen Sensoren
so dass man
Beschädigungen entdecken kann dann gibt
es ein Signal zurück an den Betreiber
der kann ein reparatur-team beauftragen
und dann wird nachgeguckt was direkt
kaputt ist und was instand gesetzt
werden muss geschützt gegen
Sabotageakte das bewusste Einwirken auf
diese Anlagen das gibt es so nicht
natürlich und das haben wir in den
Beitrag eben gesehen ist die
Bundespolizei gelegentlich auch die
Marine auf See unterwegs und versucht
ein Lagebild zu bekommen aufgrund der
ganzen Menge von kritischer
Infrastruktur die wir mittlerweile im
Maritim Umfeld haben sei es in der
Ostsee oder auch in der Nordsee ist es
natürlich schwer ein lückenloses Bild
darüber zu bekommen
und was würde dann aber passieren also
Sie haben es angesprochen da ist viel
kritische Infrastruktur unter Wasser
Gasstrom Internet was wir natürlich alle
brauchen also was würde passieren wenn
da quasi noch mehr beschädigt würde ne
was was droht uns da schlimmsten Falls
zu den meisten Einrichtungen die wir auf
See haben haben wir Redundanzen gerade
bei den Datenkabeln gibt es Resonanzen
es gab Anfang des Jahres ein
Zwischenfall zwischen Spitzbergen und in
norwegischen Festland da liegen zwei
Datenkabel die mit der small Sat
Bodenstation in Spitzbergen verbunden
sind worüber sehr viel Daten
versendet werden geteilt werden verteilt
werden dass ein Kabel auch beschädigt
worden man hat das zweite Kabel das
wirkt als Redundanz somit hat es erstmal
effektiv keine Auswirkungen gehabt
sollten natürlich mehrere dieser Kabel
Pipelines Offshore Windparks beschädigt
werden dann besteht die Gefahr dass ein
direkter Auswirkung auf die Wirtschaft
auf das tägliche Leben deutlich spürbar
sind
noch eine weitere Frage aus dem Stream
wenn man jetzt auf die Spurensuche geht
das stellt sich hier Dell Erdbeer
Youtube gefragt schwierig vor wie
schwierig wird das denn also unter
Wasser da jetzt den Auslöser zu finden
unter Wasser auch das Leck zu schließen
das muss man ja auch sagen da dritt ja
gerade Gas aus das ist auch eine
Klimakatastrophe also wie schwierig wird
das einmal die Spurensuche und dann
natürlich auch das Leck zu schließen
das ist gerade unter Wasser ungemein
schwierig also das leckt zu schließen
man kann sagen dass diese beiden
Pipelines so zerstört sind dass sie
großflächig instand gesetzt werden
müssten wenn das gewollt ist zur
Spurensuche gerade unter Wasser jeder
Hinweis den ich vielleicht bekommen
könnte ist natürlich auch den
Witterungsbedingungen unter Wasser den
Umwelteinflüssen ausgesetzt verschwindet
schnell gerade nach so einer Explosion
die ist wahrscheinlich wahr wird auch
vieles weggespült ich halte es für sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass man irgendwelche
Anzeichen
findet die direkt zurückverfolgbar sind
man kann nur anhand von Indizien
versuchen Schlüsse zu bekommen und ohne
sage ich mal dass irgendein Akteur nach
vorne tritt und sagt wir waren es oder
es wird irgendwie über leaks sowas nach
außen getragen halte jetzt für nahezu
unmöglich dass auch wirklich
zurückzuverfolgen
wir können gleich noch mehrere Fragen
mit Ihnen beantworten schauen aber jetzt
ganz kurz auf die EU und die NATO also
die Reaktion die politischen Reaktionen
denn auch EU und NATO gehen von Sabotage
aus glauben also auch nicht an einen
Zufall und diese Reaktionen aus Brüssel
die hat Isabel Schäfers für uns
zusammengefasst
immer weiter strömt Gas aus den
zerstörten pipelineabschnitten in die
Ostsee die legs sei nicht durch Seebeben
sondern durch Detonationen entstanden so
die Experten auch in Brüssel ist man
sich einig es handelte sich um eine
vorsätzliche Störung die EU kündigt
deshalb schriftlich eine gemeinsame
Reaktion an und droht mit Gegenmaßnahmen
die eu-kommissionspräsidentin schreibt
von der stärksten möglichen Antwort was
genau das heißt und gegen wen sich diese
Antwort eigentlich richten soll bleibt
offiziell ungesagt
wir sind selbstverständlich in Kontakt
mit den Mitgliedstaaten und unterstützen
jede Form der Aufklärung um Klarheit
darüber zu bekommen von wem diese
Sabotage ausging und natürlich
unternehmen wir Schritte um unsere
Energiesicherheit besser zu schützen
auch in Berlin spricht man von einem
beunruhigenden Ereignis die
Verantwortlichen müssten schnell
identifiziert werden
unsere Marine wird sich mit ihrer
Expertise bei der Aufklärung Einbringen
der mutmaßliche Sabotageakt an den
ostsee-pipelines führt uns erneut vor
Augen dass wir auf kritische
Infrastruktur angewiesen sind auch unter
Wasser nur wenige sprechen heute offen
aus was viele für möglich halten und
Militärexperten für wahrscheinlich das
Russland involviert ist
man könnte in Betracht ziehen dass es
Russland einen Vorteil bringt den
europäischen Energiemarkt noch weiter zu
destabilisieren und diesbezüglich
weitere Unsicherheit zu schaffen
Russland weist den Vorwurf als dumm und
absurd zurück das weiterhin austretende
Gas behindert laut dänischer Regierung
bisher die Untersuchung der lex eine
Inspektion sei erst in ein bis zwei
Wochen möglich
und wir können jetzt sprechen mit Isabel
Schäfers live in Brüssel Isabel wir
haben gerade in deinem Stück gehört dass
dauert natürlich alles noch ein wenig
bis man da an die Pipeline auch wirklich
ran kann aber wie versucht die EU das
denn nun aufzuklären also gibt es da
Zusammenarbeit gibt es da Pläne was ist
da schon bekannt also erstmal ist das
natürlich eine Sache von von Schweden
und Dänemark das aufzuklären aber hier
wurde heute total deutlich dass alle
sehr gewillt sind da jede mögliche
Unterstützung zu liefern die
EU-Kommission hat davon gesprochen dass
man bereits mit den Mitgliedstaaten in
Kontakt sei und auch aus Berlin zum
Beispiel kam jetzt schon die Ankündigung
dass dort Unterstützung geliefert werden
soll die Verteidigungsministerin hat ja
angekündigt auch die Marine dorthin
schicken zu wollen um bei dieser
Aufklärung zu helfen das größte Problem
ist jetzt gerade erst mal diese Zeit das
haben wir ja eben gehört ein bis zwei
Wochen wird das wohl noch dauern so
lange strömt da noch Gas raus und man
kann da gar nicht wirklich untersuchen
und dann werden aber wohl EU die
EU-Länder und auch wahrscheinlich
natoländer alle Möglichkeiten liefern
die sie haben um da unter Wasser an
diese Lex zu untersuchen und möglichst
schnell dann auch nach diesen ein bis
zwei Wochen eine Aufklärung zu bringen
in deinem Beitrag haben wir auch gehört
also es gibt einige die davon ausgehen
Russland sei involviert Russland selbst
weiß das zurück der Chef Diplomat Borell
sagte jede absichtliche Störung der
Energieinfrastruktur sei absolut
inakzeptabel und werde mit einer Zitat
robusten und gemeinsamen Reaktion
beantwortet aber damit meint er nicht
ganz klar Russlands im aktuellen
Zeitpunkt so haben wir das richtig
verstanden oder also er sagt nicht wen
er damit meint wir haben jetzt eben
gerade auch gehört dass Experten davon
ausgehen dass es sich um den staatlichen
Akteur handeln muss der der das ganze
verursacht hat und eigentlich sind sich
Militärexperten wenn man die heute hört
ziemlich sicher dass es eben einen
staatliche Akteur und sehr
wahrscheinlich auch Russland sein muss
aber auf der politischen Ebene ist es
auffällig wie zurückhaltend Dahle sind
da gibt es eigentlich keinerlei
Äußerungen wo Russland direkt attackiert
wird auch nicht genannt wird da sind
alle sehr vorsichtig von Seiten der EU
und der NATO gibt es ja sowieso
eigentlich nur schriftliche Äußerungen
außer in kurzer sehr vorsichtiger O-Ton
aus der Kommission den wir eben gehört
haben wo es jetzt um die Zusammenarbeit
geht aber ansonsten sagen alle sehr sehr
klar dass es sich um Sabotage handelt
und kündigen ganz klare Reaktionen an
also eigentlich eine sehr schnelle und
auch sehr sehr offensive Ankündigung
aber was was Mutmaßungen angeht wer
dahinter steckt da halten sich alle
erstaunlich zurück auch in Berlin da hat
man heute nichts gehört da waren alle
sehr darauf bedacht noch mal zu betonen
das ist jetzt eben darauf auf ankommt
erstmal aufzuklären bevor man dann sagt
gegen wen sich diese Reaktionen
überhaupt richten sollen also das war
schon auffällig heute
gleichzeitig aber weil wir jetzt auch
die Möglichkeit haben mit dir zu
sprechen die EU-Kommission nämlich zum
Stichwort Russland die hat heute neue
Sanktionen gegen Russland vorgeschlagen
wegen des angriffskriegs in der Ukraine
also erhöht den Druck was steht denn da
neues drin
ja also diese Sanktion dass die jetzt
gerade heute kamen das war tatsächlich
ein Zufall das hat jetzt wirklich nichts
mit diesen mit dieser Sabotage zu tun
aber wenn jetzt heute die Rede war von
von Reaktionen und und harten
Gegenmaßnahmen dann haben natürlich auch
alle an Sanktionen gedacht diese
Sanktionen hier heute die sind schon
länger im Gespräch man wollte eben die
die sanktionspakete die es schon gibt
weiter aktualisieren und auch aufstocken
und jetzt durch diese Ankündigung der
teilmobilisierung und auch durch diese
scheinreferenten hat die EU dann noch
mal mehr Druck gehabt und auch die Druck
gemacht da jetzt wirklich voranzugehen
was die Sanktionen angeht und deswegen
hat die EU-Kommission eben heute ein
neues Paket vorgestellt da geht es
erstmal auch um eine Weiterführung von
Dingen die es schon vorher in den
Paketen gab die einfach jetzt ein
bisschen ausgeweitet werden zum Beispiel
auch Einreiseverbote und
vermögenssperren für weitere Personen
die jetzt gelistet werden dann geht es
aber auch um weiter ein- und
ausfuhrverbote also Produkte die jetzt
weitergelistet werden da geht es ganz
viel auch um Schlüsseltechnologien die
Russland eben nicht mehr zur Verfügung
gestellt werden sollen und was Neues ist
ein Verbot für EU-Bürger in russischen
Staatsunternehmen Aufsichtsräten zu
sitzen da denkt man ja gleich an Gerhard
Schröder aber man hört auch dass es
nicht auf ihn zugeschnitten sein soll
sondern dass es auch da um den Fluss von
Know-how in russische Unternehmen geht
den man hier verhindern will der größte
Punkt in diesem ganzen Paket und warum
man das jetzt auch so schnell eigentlich
verabschieden wollte das ist eigentlich
ein Ölpreis Deckel der wurde schon von
den G7 Staaten vereinbart und auch
umgesetzt und da wartet jetzt vor allem
auch die USA eigentlich dass auch die EU
da jetzt hinterherzieht das ist aber
auch gleichzeitig der Punkt der am
umstrittensten ist
danke für deine Einschätzung heute Abend
aus Brüssel live Isabel Schäfers danke
und wir können jetzt noch mehr Fragen
ich habe sie alle im Blick ich sehe euch
interessiert das Thema auch und ihr habt
einige Fragen und wir haben jetzt noch
mal die Möglichkeit zu sprechen mit
Fregattenkapitän gehören Swiss Tech er
ist Experte für maritime Sicherheit in
der Ostsee und uns jetzt noch mal
zugeschaltet wir hatten gerade eben die
Perspektive der EU und auch die Haltung
der EU natürlich dass man da geschlossen
auf jeden Fall jetzt schauen möchte was
da dahinter steckt vieles ist noch
unklar aber wir können ja mal darüber
sprechen dass es auch was was ich
gelesen habe was viele interessiert wer
ist denn für den Schutz dieser
Infrastruktur der kritischen und
Infrastruktur unter Wasser dann
eigentlich zuständig wer versichert das
wird das geschützt von eu-nato sind das
die einzelnen Länder erklären Sie uns
mal ein bisschen genauer wie das läuft
also zunächst einmal muss man sagen dass
diese Infrastruktur überwiegend in
privatwirtschaftlicher Hand ist das
heißt der Eigentümer ist natürlich
verantwortlich für seine Infrastruktur
wie ich vorhin schon erwähnte gibt es
Sensoren die dem Eigentümer Indikation
geben wenn da was kaputt geht repariert
werden muss aber ein umfassenden Schutz
gegen Sabotage gibt es nicht das können
ja auch nur wenige dazu brauche ich
wirklich polizeilich ausgebildete Kräfte
oder
marinekräfte die ein Lagebild aufrecht
erhalten und gegen gegebenenfalls dann
auch Akteure die eine Sabotage planen
abschrecken oder auch abwehren das
könnten ganz kurz reingehen weil da gibt
es nämlich die mehrere Fragen dazu bei
uns bei Facebook wieso gibt es denn
keine Überwachung der NATO um ebenso
potenzielle Saboteure zu entdecken das
fragen sich ganz viele
also wie vorhin schon angeklungen ist
erstmals gibt es eine Vielzahl dieser
maritimen Infrastruktur so groß dass es
schwer ist das Ganze kontinuierlich zu
überwachen da bräuchte ich ganz viel
Kräfte und Mittel zum anderen ist auch
die maritime Domäne das muss man ganz
ehrlich eingestehen in den letzten
Jahren etwas vernachlässigt worden wir
haben immer weniger Schiffe in den
Streitkräften auch
Polizei See Polizei hat immer weniger
Einheiten gehabt
Überwachungsanlagen Radaranlagen an Land
um Schiffsverkehr zu kontrollieren sind
abgebaut worden da haben wir deutlich
Nachholbedarf das müsste man erstmal
wieder forcieren um sich dieses Lagebild
auch zu ermöglichen damit es das mal
kontinuierlich gibt damit ich weiß was
passiert auf See wer ist da alles
unterwegs und dann auch gegebenenfalls
mit entsprechenden Kräften die in einer
gewissen Bereitschaft sind die dürfen ja
nicht so lange brauchen um dann zum
Einsatzort zu kommen eingreifen zu
können
und wird der Schutz jetzt aber mehr
ausgebaut ganz grundsätzlich gibt es
dazu jetzt schon mehr Infos weil das war
ja jetzt nicht nichts ne also diese drei
legs diese drei sehr großen legs gibt es
da jetzt schon Gespräche
also direkte Gespräche im Zusammenhang
mit den Lex ist mir jetzt erstmal nicht
bekannt natürlich ist das Thema erstmal
virulent mir ist sehr wohl bewusst dass
das Thema der kritischen maritimen
Infrastruktur und der maritimen Räume
unter anderem auch auf der Agenda der
NATO steht im Juni hatte man den Gipfel
der NATO gehabt da ist das auch in das
strategische Konzept eingeflossen und
man hat gewisse Regionen identifiziert
den man in Zukunft mehr Aufmerksamkeit
schenken will da gehört der hohe Norden
der Nordatlantik Nordsee bis hin zur
Ostsee auch dazu und das Thema der
Verwundbarkeiten durch kritische
Infrastruktur dem will man sich auch
mehr widmen nun hat man wie bereits
erwähnt relativ wenig Kapazitäten
Fähigkeiten
derzeitig die muss man auch erstmal
aufstellen das passiert leider auch
nicht von heute auf morgen da wird es
Entwicklungen geben im Ostseeraum aber
auch in der Nordsee im Nordatlantik wo
diese gerade wichtigen Datenkabel auch
verlegt sind die werden wir aber erst
über die Zeit wahrnehmen können noch
sind wir muss man eingestehen relativ
verwundbar
ich schaue noch mal in die Kommentare
und möchte da gerne noch welche
aufgreifen ich habe mich hier zum einen
gefragt hier ist eine Frage von extract
of pineapple Glen nennt er sich bei
Youtube also er möchte gerne wissen
durch Nord Stream 1 und 2 wurde nichts
mehr geliefert und sollte es ja auch
weiterhin erstmal nicht welchen Sinn
macht dann so ein Sabotageakt
aus meiner Sicht würde ich jetzt zwei
Effekte
aufführen der erste Effekt ist natürlich
der auf den Energiemarkt in den letzten
Tagen hat man beobachten können dass die
Preise für Erdgas auf dem Energiemarkt
wieder abgesackt sind
niedriger geworden seit dieser Sabotage
sind sie wieder gestiegen das hat einen
Zusammenhang der zweite Effekt das ist
mehr so ein kognitiver psychologischer
Effekt es zeigt sehr deutlich auf wie
verwundbar wie wir sind als Gesellschaft
durch diese maritime Infrastruktur es
erzeugt vielleicht auch ein gewisses
Gefühl von Angst auch wenn es
Redundanzen gibt das ist so dieser
zweite Effekt der dadurch generiert
wurde man treibt also einen Angstzustand
weiterhin trägt ihn in die Gesellschaft
rein
das beantwortet hoffentlich die Frage
ich habe sie mehrfach gelesen auch von
anderen Usern ich hätte hier noch eine
Frage die mehrfach auch kam und zwar ob
theoretisch auch etwas in die Pipeline
gebracht worden sein könnte also das ist
kein Angriff von außen war sondern von
innerhalb dieser Pipeline ist sowas
denkbar
das habe ich heute auch schon mehrfach
gehört es gibt gewisse
wartungseinrichtungen innerhalb von
Pipelines die kann man einbringen das
sind auch mehrere Meter große
Art Drohnen würde ich mal sagen die
werden natürlich durch den Druck der
Pipeline dann bewegt innerhalb der
Pipeline dazu brauche ich einen
öffnungstor um das einzubringen das gibt
es bei den nordstream Pipelines auf
russischer Seite durch den Druck fließen
oder ja bewegen die sich dann bis nach
Deutschland und müssen in Deutschland
dann wieder rausgenommen werden
ausgenommen werden also diese
Möglichkeit gäbe es diese
wartungsdrohnen wartungsmittel die es da
gibt die sind auch mit unterschiedlichen
Sensoren ausgestattet um zum Beispiel
Fehler in der innerhalb der Pipeline
festzustellen oder gegebenenfalls
kleinere Arbeiten auch durchzuführen
und noch mehr Fragen also es beschäftigt
viele das Thema und zwar ja sie haben
sich dazu schon geäußert aber da ist
doch noch häufiger kam würde ich noch
mal nachfragen welche Akteure abgesehen
von Russland kommen denn für eine solche
Sabotage in Frage und wird es möglich
sein schließt sich noch anderen diese
Frage das überhaupt in Zukunft dann zu
vermeiden könnten Sie sich dazu noch mal
äußern
also zu den Akteuren vielleicht generell
wenn man sich einmal den Überblick im
Ostseeraum verschafft wer hat denn zum
Beispiel U-Boote da gibt es nicht so
viel Länder da gibt es Deutschland wir
haben U-Boote ja Schweden hat U-Boote
polen hatte mal eins also soweit ich
informiert bin ist das aber zurzeit
nicht mehr einsatzfähig
und dann gibt es Russland die haben auch
noch ein U-Boot dauerhaft in der Ostsee
nach offiziellen Aussagen wird das aber
im Schwerpunkt zu Forschungszwecken
genutzt
die Frage der U-Boote hatte ich vorhin
schon mal aufgenommen und gesagt naja
ich halte das persönlich für
unwahrscheinlich war auch gerade dass
detektieren das Feststellen von
u-boot-bewegungen relativ gut in der
Ostsee möglich ist durch die flachen
Zugänge den man dann in einem tiefen
Gebiet ist
da würde ich das erstmal beiseite packen
Drohnen unter Wasser
Systeme die sich in diesem
dieser Art bewegen können und natürlich
auch Arbeiten durchführen können und
Explosivstoffe mitführen können das
haben auch nicht so viele Russland ja
weil Deutschland würde ich sagen wir
haben auch gewisse Systeme die das
ermöglichen aber in Verbindung mit den
Explosivstoffen gerade da kommen nur
wirklich ganz wenige in Frage das so
meiner Kenntnis nach ist es im
Schwerpunkt gerade Russland die so etwas
entwickelt haben
und dann vielleicht zum Schluss noch mal
die Frage für uns alle also wie viel
Sorge müssen wir haben dass das künftig
also auch andere Infrastruktur kritische
Infrastruktur betreffen könnte könnte
das wieder passieren
ja die Gefahr ist da und sie wird weiter
auch vorhanden sein gerade so lange wir
auch noch in diesem
konfrontationszustand mit Russland sind
solange Russland seine Politik der
Aggression weiter fortsetzt können
wir nicht ausschließen dass es wieder zu
Akten von Sabotage kommt das kann
kritische Infrastruktur sein gerade in
der maritimen Umwelt haben wir ja
aufgezeigt wie viel es da gibt das kann
aber auch irgendwann ganz andere
Versorgungswege sein an Land wo zum
Beispiel
Unterstützungsleistungen für die Ukraine
durchlaufen das halte ich durchaus für
nicht ausgeschlossen von daher das
Risiko besteht leider und es liegt nun
an uns vor allen Dingen unserer Politik
dementsprechend auch Maßnahmen zum
Schutz zu ergreifen
sagt Göran swistake Experte für maritime
Sicherheit in der Ostsee vielen Dank
dass Sie bei uns zu Gast waren heute
Abend gerne und ich bin mir sicher dass
das Thema uns natürlich noch weiter
beschäftigen wird denn es dauert jetzt
eine Weile das haben wir ja auch gelernt
noch ein paar Tage im Zweifel auch ein
paar Wochen noch bis da überhaupt
richtige Ergebnisse vorliegen und man
konkreter weiß wer das war was passiert
ist daran wird jetzt wohl mit Hochdruck
gearbeitet wir behalten das für euch im
Auge das ganz bestimmt und seid gerne
auch beim nächsten Mal dabei und stellt
gerne wieder so viele Fragen vielen Dank
dass ihr dabei wart und bis zum nächsten
Mal bis dahin tschüss